[Musique]
c'est à saint leu que s'est déroulée la
dernière journée de visite à la réunion
de patrick jarry maire de nanterre et
président de la fédération nationale des
entreprises publiques locales il a dans
un premier temps été accueillis au musée
du sel par béatrice sigismeau vice
président du département entouré de
l'équipe de la spl eden qu'elle préside
et qui assure l'exploitation des salines
découvre un endroit c'est c'est magique
avec la mer la montagne
le sucre le sel voilà et puis non je
suis très très surpris qu'une une
société publique locale donc
produisent du sel et puis demain et dans
le commercialiser je le disais tout à
l'heure à la présidente que
quand je dirais ça
retour sur le continent peut-être au
prochain congrès ddd épais la tour il
faudra quelques elle surtout et certifie
que ce que je dis et est exact j'ai peur
que les gens pensent que j'ai beaucoup
d'imagination et la journée s'est
poursuivie à mascara jardin botanique de
la réunion s'est déroulée la
présentation de l'équipe de la spl eden
à tour de rôle les agents ont livré des
témoignages liés à leur activité leur
parcours chez nous la paix tout
connaître les plans
et pour les transferts les clubs landais
nettoyer connecter différents
modèles du salat
et puis
chaque année la sp liden en
collaboration avec pôle emploi recrute
plus de 300 bénéficiaires du rsa mhz
pour les inscrire dans le cadre d'un
parcours emploi compétences pour
renforcer cet accompagnement une
signature de convention de partenariat
s'est tenue entre le directeur général
de la spa laden et la directrice
régionale de pôle emploi réunion
alors c'est une convention qui
contractualise le partenariat que nous
avons depuis deux ans et demi avec la
spn eden et qui permet justement un pôle
emploi d'accompagner la spn dans le
recrutement et l'accompagnement des
demandeurs d'emploi que nous mettons à
la disposition de cette structure pour
qu'ils puissent être formés tutoré pour
accéder à terme un emploi pérenne il ya
une prise en compte de l'humain et
chaque personne sera accompagné pour
monter en compétences et à la fin du
contrat
aura la capacité d' avait aussi cherché
un projet qui correspond à un parcours
qui correspond à son propre projet et
pour tout cela on a les équipes de sp
l'éden qui les accompagnent mais on ne
peut pas le faire seul il faut qu'on
puisse aussi travaillé en étroite
collaboration avec pôle emploi pour
qu'il puisse nous accompagner sur les
différentes étapes et amener chaque
personne à être dans ce parcours de
professionnalisation
et de trouver la voie de son propre
projet d initiative saluée par patrick
jarry pour qui la sp l'éden est un
modèle à l'échelle nationale
[Musique]